Here we are on the set of The Changeling.
This is Kelly Marcel, showrunner and creator of The Changeling.
And this is Victor LaValle, author of The Changeling novel.
And we’re here at apartment 305, the home of Apollo and Emma, our heroic leads.
Shall we go inside?
Let’s go.
Here we are in baby Brian’s bedroom, the scene of the crime.
But before we get to those terrible things,
some of my favorite details include the curtain that hangs here
where you can see the motif of the forest coming in,
so that you constantly feel like the outside world iscreeping in,
and what’s creeping in with it.
And all of these things become very important in Season 1.
And then one of the other really magically things is this book.
To the Waters and the Wild.
It’s a good one.
A little children’s book my father read to me.
It tells a creepy but wonderful tale that we really appreciated.
It was kind of incredible
Yes.
how spot on this book is
when we talk about the story of our show.
Absolutely.
The young one is gone,
but they’ll never know.
In its place, a thing without life,
hard and cold.
Where are you?
Not a baby!
Why don’t we check Apollo and Emma’s bedroom now?
Let’s do it.
We have a few things here as well that speak to the themes of our show
that have been planted by Lester,our production designer.
And it’s another place where Lester has brought the outside world in, so you’ll see
forests and boats.
And as a little Easter egg, Apollo has a coat, inside that coat is a forest.
The woods plays a very large part in the creeping dread of the tale.
And there’s more forests over here.
And the fact that Apollo and Emma are sleeping under this painting
only gains significance and power asyou get to know more and more about what might be being suggested.
We go here into the kitchen,
a place of great horror in all the best ways.
But it’s not only a place for hard times.
One of the sweet details is that Emma is a real world traveler.
And so some of these magnets are from some of the places where we imagine she had traveled to.
One of the places she goes to is Brazil.
She brings magic back.
That magic has huge repercussions for everybody.
People don’t just disappear.
Tell me your life’s voyage.
And I will tell you who you are.